[Music]
what are you reading about coronavirus
this is of great interest to me I've
been tracking it very closely for a few
weeks and I know this is topical but I
do think that in a sense there's a
parallel to the expression and I'm gonna
butcher this and I'm afraid I don't know
the attribution but that adversity
doesn't build character it reveals
character and I do think that with the
let's call it threat on one hand panic
on the other and they're not totally
separate everything going on with
coronavirus the challenges of parsing
good from bad information reliable from
unreliable information many of the
frailties and thinking or logic or meta
rationality that otherwise would go
somewhat unnoticed day to day are
becoming much more pronounced in a lot
of people and many of them and maybe
present company included or not aware
just how those things are manifesting so
what are you what are you reading and
how are you thinking about this this
particular current of iris we're
speaking in very early March yes and it
seems to me there are several distinct
episodes one is Wuhan there's other
parts of China the South Korea Japan
Singapore northern Italy Washington
State princess diamond cruise ship and
the different numbers from these
separate locations they don't really add
up
no so I'm treating it like a Sherlock
Holmes puzzle how do we make sense of
all of these collectively comparing them
to each other so yes of course there are
data mistakes but what's your theory of
data mistakes where they all fit
together and I still actually don't find
a way of making it add up so I'm trying
not to approach it as like a lecturer
like telling everyone do this don't do
that wash your hands probably good
advice but is a kind of puzzle and to
stay open about it and see what it
brings me
and also see which of the responses are
the best ones so far Singapore is
looking quite good but you know there's
plenty of play left so to speak and the
United States it seems has let the
coronavirus get into its health care
system and it did nothing about it for
six weeks in what could end up being
really a kind of huge crime of omission
yeah you know I'm struggling with with
where to go with this because you know I
recognize we have a large audience
listening how do you how do you
currently plan to increase the
resolution on those puzzle pieces or to
continue informing yourself in such a
way that the picture becomes clearer and
not more difficult to make out how do
you think about information consumption
there's more data every day and I will
write out the puzzles as I find them and
try to think them through as I write
them out and then get feedback and I'm
not sure where all arrived with this one
hopes of course it just goes away and
the puzzles remain that puzzles at this
point that's seeming a bit less likely
than it had been so I'm afraid to say I
think we're gonna find out more than we
want to know you know I'm not really
worried about that like if it all
remains unresolved I can just go away
and celebrate right aside from it for
instance to me Johns Hopkins has a very
good daily newsletter which I would
consider reasonably uncharged
politically speaking
you had mentioned someone on Twitter who
you follow and I'm blanking on the name
it's Helen Brown's whale she's public
health in Toronto how do you spell that
last name it's BR ans wel L I believe
are there any other particular sources
of information or other people you are
following who you find to be reasonably
level-headed about how there
approaching and analyzing this there's
four or five I don't remember their
Twitter handles by memory but you know
they're in the list of people I follow
if you just go through that it will be
pretty clear which ones they are okay
great and then I find by being out there
writing about it in an open non
hysterical way I'm just sent a flood of
useful information
yeah and that's arguably my main source
and I don't mean to say I trust it all
but you cross check and you think and
then you talk to people you know and you
get a bit further yeah
you